and we are laughs welcome to the i lords
podcast episode number 86 and it's
another glorious Sunday we're back at
the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
extremely excited about a special guest
and we've got UFC 230 Nintendo smash
direct Red Dead Redemption to issue
Black Friday and EXO 2018 predictions
and console exclusive sales to discuss
so we're gonna get right into it I won
and rusev law was not only a huge friend
to the realm but truly has the potential
to be one of the most original content
creators in the game this law is a true
talent in the realm of infotainment with
fantastic humor and owner of one of the
very best video game protagonists series
the hero a lot introducing the creator
host of the potentially perfect youtube
channel the Lord we can't want to keep
it true about good old grandpa Nintendo
always a perfect making his return into
the realm of the Lord's mommy's Lord
Aleppo how you doing sir I've been
trying to learn just how to editing and
stuff like that it's been crazy with
with a new segment and then trying to
find time to game and it's oh it's been
yeah
I finished it I was like oh man you
started to pour it on to force him now I
know back channels yesterday he was sick
so obviously this is conversation of
jokes and joking manner so I really
don't want
really go in on him because he's running
from the pole the pole will still be
there next week don't worry about a week
feel a whole lot better uh you know our
wishes go out to him you know because
listen losing to them MPD's with the
single player selfish experience and
also thus after Dallas mr. Flamm profile
Illuminati and Lord patreon of the iron
bank
mommy's Lord sorry man what's up guys
I'm barely awake I was up late UFC and a
whole bunch of stuff birthday party and
when I came home biggest of last touches
I saw all right suffering about Red Dead
I'm like oh someone gonna be under done
I was watching UFC as well playing red
that I'm like I think from now and from
now until I finish the game like every
week I'll give a little mini Chronicle
of what I'm doing because I'm not I'm
not really doing much of the story as
soon as I had a chance to get out into
the open world I'll just be messing
around or hunting challenges just like
doing bounties and stuff like that I
haven't really done much story so that
sounds like everybody that's playing
that game some people want to be minding
the story I don't want it to end so
that's gonna be the last thing I do
um but yesterday man there were two
instances they were kind of crazy so the
first one was I was in the bayou right
you know and I was you know raiding some
all the bushes waiting cabins and they
seemed you know they seemed abandoned
they seem kind of decrepit run down go
into these cabins over you see a lot of
evidence of Voodoo like a lot and like
all true Satan's cave oh I know there's
more than Satan's cave is it's an entire
bayou of stuff going down so so I raid
these places I find whatever I can find
and I'm
even and it just it there was nothing
really the out of the ordinary right so
as I'm leaving the by you raise that you
cross that kind of takes you back to
like that like normal and I see a body
hanging from a tree whoa all right hold
up let me get off the course let me see
if I can if this guy has something on I
wanted to rate him I want to loot him -
I was so as I get off my horse right I
here like this and it was nighttime was
weird I'm like what the hell so I turn
around like I'm so I try to loot the
dude and I realize I probably have to
shoot him down off the noose - yeah all
of a sudden out of the trees come
running these two um they look like just
look like they're cultists like oh why
you cultures that never leave the Bayou
journey and so the they come running at
me the first one I'm able to shoot him
and kill him had my sawed-off shotgun
equation popped up but then that it's a
slow recoilless at a slow reload so this
is a good one that was coming right
behind me guys he ran right into me with
a freaking six-inch knife and deaded me
right you know it was the most it was
beautiful ambush into the world I'm like
alright I'm gonna go back I want to see
what's going on who these they weren't
there so right now that's a mystery shut
up shout the cat that he said he wasn't
about you after watch it on Netflix he
said he got right about it is the thing
about this game is right I haven't done
any story stuff I don't even know this
any story stuff associated with this
this is just in the world as though the
stories that I'm hearing and then the
second thing is if you see my last post
last night on come out at night
happily merrily raiding barns and I and
I found something course you know we
have the Incredible Hulk of this aka XS
game ok Google I know Google's or that
one the Lord of combat sports was a man
of his convictions demands nothing less
than that premium experience and is the
leader of the fraud alert movement
listen I was a call floor Dometic but I
can't do that and I can't call food on a
lot of people to speak because they're
playing with their love and a lot of
people love to shout out to Cali
realness Chris follow them on Twitter he
finished that game he put a hundred
hours in mum that man has not slept okay
I call him young adderall dude I'm
finding legendary carcasses my taxidermy
is crazy I'm like wow I really can't
with you right now
but uh this week yo you want a bio and a
son just like they're just awesome
people your friends friends I got
friends please listen y'all think I'm
trolling you right now first of all I'm
not trolling my name on on PlayStation
Network is Xbox 360 level oh one
right ringing there talk to me
alright please because I literally am
stuck in no-man's land and having FOMO
looking at my xbox knowing that is mad
joy going on even if we not in the same
game people in the same parties talking
or in its joy going on in the Xbox
there's no joy in that place I did my
arms fight a man complete a hundred
percent I told you he's the difficult
game Conqueror right so what i'ma start
doing is stripping him of his title I'm
doing gotta warn now I'm forty percent
finished with it now so I'm gonna knock
that snoozefest off cuz it's a snooze
fest alright all that crap y'all talking
about Dave Murray year garbage great hot
carpet all right when you walk in a room
and then they give you a visible barrier
here invisible barrier here killed the
animals progressed garbage now how that
was we was doing that on PlayStation 1
back in the days they then changed the
formula they just updated the graphics
um so and when I'm on a scum podcast I'm
gonna give my thoughts on it because me
and action Lucas don't go in on that
game and I'm gonna go for my real
thoughts on that game on what I really
think about the theories other game of
behind that game um but it didn't change
that's not no game of the year and if
anybody's sitting there thinking that
they're smart where's that even a
contender they don't feel like the
heavyweights
you understand what it is those people
probably won didn't buy the game too
didn't really play the game three
doesn't understand exactly what game
design is I want you to go on top of
them
the avenges of tower look around
freefall all the way down to the ground
then slide your weight all across
Manhattan to uptown Harlem without it
loading and pausing stopping and slowing
down for you all right
Red Dead we'll have some words for you
though yeah well you know what um I
haven't played Red Dead so I can't say
anything about it okay alright I'm not
gonna sit and keep opinion on a game
based on other people's opinion without
my my facts to bring to the table
there's no a new king it won't it won't
move to me yeah I mean you you
appreciate it for what it is but it's
just vitamins more your your type that's
real medications in the building stat
Lord meds last-minute come through in
the realm are you doing sir Destiny's
been the hot monkey get him up to 600
he's almost did shout out to green Mason
he's at 600 that game has did what it
was supposed to do and I know it took a
long time for it to get to that journey
to that spot that where we was playing
destiny and people feeling like destiny
you know fell off and it was in the
bushes because it wasn't a bush it for a
long time but they got back to feeling
of when you get an exotic yes everybody
in the womb stops what they're doing I
don't care what game they're playing and
they said what which one did you get now
what did you do doing it okay I gotta go
do that and it's a great feeling now
when you get an exotic is even a better
surprise when you go to the mailbox at
the postman and he said
once it did I miss it what was I doing
so bad
listen I listen to flashpoint this week
and I listened to low Cognito talk to
lordy bonta's about catching a meatball
[Laughter]
kognito said he didn't understand what
people talk about before the meatball so
this is the first round they pretty much
watched the first team write and give it
and then the second round load up and
they call it prime well he think it is
gone gone like everything and they gonna
put the weld down it's gonna make it
happen he said to me all showed up and
he was deal with randos so I don't know
how that must have felt cuz you could
yell out to your team no it's late right
that low primeval thing in the gambit
more for the pitfalls don't know what
you saying a meatball it's it's like
this random occurrence this random boss
that the chances of it spawning in the
middle of this game mode is very low but
if it comes out that's just if you give
your team beats it also you have to also
win so if this thing spawn randomly
comes out you beat it that's what gives
you a chance for this so it's like
experience it's like those little
moments the whisper and all these little
quests destiny Bungie
but I honestly believe Bungie always
knew what we needed I believe and I will
constantly sit there with sovereign that
Activision was the overlords being
overbearing father in these dues so
funny you say that I had a good
conversation as Comcast about this try
to give him a forte
well you know we were all going it was
actually a great gumbo slow more than
the crew and it was about like you know
now they obviously Jesse's in a good
place but at the same time it's like yo
like why who you think who you blame
most responsible for like the early
things and it was funny you would kind
of say in any mode I think most of the
agreement with you King and Activision
is definitely like that you know what
that analogy they use is like remember
like that puff used to sign our acts you
don't say
get cheesecake girl like blame right
mates like if you if you're trying to
get on you shopping you're demoing shop
and nobody's listening but Activision
like you sign this 10 year decision even
though you know probably deal probably
was the greatest but yeah we actually
talked on shout out to look in the crew
now episode yesterday yeah that's not my
cue to I gotta watch that o2 as well
I've tried I tried to watch everybody's
pocket but I I feel that they stepped
away from Bungie and let Bungie be munch
because if they think about it and I
really want you to really think about
this all those things that they're doing
is in bungees DNA yes right so you can't
say that somebody woke up being
different from who the war and then like
they were something they were one way
they changed a little bit but then he
went right back to who they were mmm no
they were always that was he's like
alright Baker Aker anchor this is how
I'm gonna shut you up right now
oh no he what he needs to do is he need
not to anger me today because bull out
comes out on the 14th and it looked like
fell out of contention of everything so
what I want you to do is fall back oh
you become the fall guy for this whole
segment old blood but he said it's a
bungee fault for leaving Microsoft and
choosing to join Activision it's their
error in judgment listen I'll just say
it one last time I said it was Comcast
his deal I get what you're saying
you go to the devil that's you got to
sleep in that bed but the same remember
when they were over at Microsoft it was
kind I don't want to say slave room
concentration can kind of stuff but they
were forced to pump out nothing but halo
they didn't have that creative freedom
that they wanted so they left no doubt
what you're right and then they trying
to get on the market but if you're
shopping your demo
so all these publishers and no one's
really rock with you except this one
dude what are you really gonna do what's
the alternative to go under you left you
left the house you're trying to step out
on your own and it happened so I hear
you going with it but relax yourself you
know cuz he's gonna anger me I'm gonna
really tear apart his game shall I set
off the hard to combat real quick
because combat talk is up right now you
can get to the beginning of the
breakdown of the fight going and if you
don't have any knowledge of the
knowledge I gave you some knowledge so
you can use that with your friends but
check this out right
I knew this do they have a shot in the
world everybody why don't we have a shot
in the goddamn world
and to be honest with you I don't like
when they take guys that aren't ready
and they didn't take him from they hike
because this is you just finished
fighting like two weeks ago and they
like you fight the champ what his legs
wasn't ready y'all saw it oh what a
fight started he was backing up
attacking because somebody that's quite
a say your way for Cormier to make a
mistake you you break them in that was
the greatest idea in the world
when your man she just I don't care put
like addicts s and I don't like saying
it and cover your ears kids balls to the
walls
you should just winning them ninjas I
don't care will lose a draw
try to kill him yeah let's get into it
so so Lord Mitch I'm assuming you watch
the car last night for sure I saw this I
saw the tweet two tweets relate sir no
so give me your assessment obviously we
talked about the main that's before we
get to the me I like that you talk about
Alban I do so here she stand outs for
the card Lord man's like what are some
things that you really got excited about
and about the card overall was your
assessment um best performance is really
sign in for sure dude it's a sniper like
he would catch his Reach is crazy he's
skinny as hell but he'll still push you
off stuff and all those takedowns and
then pick him apart he walked through
yeah yeah yeah and obviously I mean the
Cormier thing it wasn't impressive
because that's exactly how I thought I
would go and honestly it was alright I
was surprised about the jacory thing I
feel bad about widening that miracle i
aughtta failed them
yeah we jump in on that too because i'm
glad you mentioned that fight that
surprised me des off did you see the
Weidman Jacare I did I did I kind of got
the feeling that did it almost felt like
Jacare was in front of Merliah he didn't
necessarily see when he hit
and how his eyes looked when he hit
because I was pretty good I got you know
it just didn't seem like for him to walk
over but was weird though so once he
walked over he's standing over him and
he oh he sees his Weidman sort of just
instinctively go for the single but not
really be doing it he didn't see his
eyes I have a feeling even see his eyes
because otherwise I don't I don't see
him doing that you know it's quick it
happens in a couple of seconds
I don't think Jack arezzo he had to
finish him off I don't think he hit him
with anything substantial but he
shouldn't have had to do that but I mean
I've seen worse situations where rats
just missed it completely laughter oh
yeah I'm not jumping on that one cuz
that was intriguing because unlike Lord
man I am a Weidman hater I've been
waiting for his fall he poked my hero
Dan but I do respect him and he's really
talented so it's just weird to see like
how far like these losses are going now
cuz it was like you know it's been who's
they Romero he lost to um anything like
knocked out like he surprised me and
then let's laugh again he really been
the same since Luke Rockhold no uncle
since they're in Lou Bravo who knows
what happened his chin down to honey was
going to him but um at the end of the
day I was surprised because it felt like
I thought chakra is the older guy yeah
they were gone King they were going at
it like summer said maybe the rough
didn't get a chance to check it and see
it and it [ __ ] and went as far as it did
but who's to be upset Wyman had I had a
run early on we seem sort of invincible
um and it just seems like when he got
really paired he caught Anderson consort
up on the down trends was joking right
and then generally just on the downward
trend he's getting older and he wasn't
necessarily the same fighter overall we
saw that wasn't for Chael um at least
the first time so I mean it's for me it
just felt like he got caught by
guys that have more varied skill sets
and and and I just stronger all-around
fighters and it just he's not there
and for whatever reason I think also
he's surrounded by people that feel to
me like they're really a lot of yes men
are in his corner and not pushing him to
the next level no I think I don't think
he has a next level I think matchmaking
got him - as far as they got him and now
when you're forced to fight people that
you don't necessarily pair up with
properly yeah and you gotta win these um
he's not winning them right you know
it's like I'm close though he's been in
all the mixes I just think that towards
the end of the fights I won he doesn't
need to be standing all the time I think
I understand not standing against Jacare
let's say but his wrestling is good
enough that if he it's late in the fight
and he's just trying to ground and pound
him and I think you should at least give
it a shot and he's just a great fighter
he's not a fighter man what do you think
about the whole like just Weidman as a
whole like his arcing Herrmann's a fight
it's tough guy I love Weidman but he's
in New York aside you know I mean he
definitely is on a downswing and he he
never evolved the wrestle boxer yeah
he's like a really big Frankie Edgar
yeah he's slow in his China's confident
and his chin is failing him yeah yeah I
mean that's pretty much what is I guess
like I said washy I was just surprised
that if out like Jacare just out tough
him you know kind of walked him down and
don't get me wrong
Jackie was getting lit his nose bro
winning and at the end of the I'm like
the younger guy is gonna prevail so when
he just dropped off my screen I'm out of
it you still go off
and raffles like broads over like stop
he no wave is that so anyone with that
but as far as the main event I was rules
he had do you think it was just my king
said I mean meme as we talked beforehand
you know this is how we saw what most
likely was gonna go I don't feel Derrick
Lewis was necessarily ready and we knew
he had a punch his chance but Natalie
had yeah I'm concerned and the last
question I'm gonna shot was on obviously
now that bones is going on with
Gustafson I've heard that oh he is not
interested in a DC bones 3 what do you
think let me tell you let me tell you
two things two things right man um this
is the reason why Cormier was so
distraught after the bones fight
somebody told him if he works really
really hard in his life because he's a
great fighter he's a great fighter
there's a difference between a great
fighter and a special fighter I see a
special fighter is Roy Jones jr.
specified as Floyd Mayweather Muhammad
Ali asked De La Hoya these are special
fighters Anderson Silva is a special
fighter special fighters can get away
with not training for a couple of days
and still come in and beat the breaks
off of great fighter right so a great
fighter has to be at his physical peak
if you looked at that Cormier fight he
was in tip the second fight was in
tip-top shape that his best you right
you right right his his body was
phenomenal for that fight because this
but his body in this fight looked like
horseradish um
but unless fight he knew that he had to
be a hundred percent to beat Jones he
knew it and he said when he got knocked
out the way he did it broke him down to
a point is there he was questioning a
whole bunch of things at that point we
got that real crime yeah yeah the one
thing that gave him solace is the fact
that he came up dirty afterwards right
and I think I think that's bones is
crust you know our all our special
fighters have a severe floor yeah right
that brings them down and I call me
I will lose their fighter bones mm-hmm
clean bones dirty bones yes whatever it
is he will lose that fight to bones
because bones no matter what is a
special fighter he knows he's special
right he will beat Cormier ten times out
of ten which add Jules wax to my high
off their coca okay a street car ba
could I be I think that it's a staff
thing I think Cormier has too I mean
don't ask too many physical attributes
over Cormier he's taller he's longer he
has some his balance is ridiculous so
Cormier strengths of being able to take
him down don't work with Jones like he
Lim he he nullifies his entire game no I
definitely I definitely say last day in
Lourdes meds um in reference today would
you like to see it all you feel like you
know what it's not even a guy I agree
with King 1% John Jones you know you can
argue DC is like a top-five fighter John
Jones I would argues the very best
fighter of all time
yes boy I see this I see this right down
low I know this is what I'm saying
okay Brock is not Derrick Lewis yeah
Brock would throw those hands on your
head mm-hmm
if he feels that's the only shot that he
got mm he would throw those hands on top
of your head and if he lands one of
those lunch boxes on the side cuz this
guy if you think I got big hands you
think I got big hands he got this he
blocks out my face his hands he learned
that lunch box or let dude head I'm
intrigued anything my daddy's gonna make
day no he's gonna make Jones and him
fight so I tell you this Cormier core
means more natural at heavyweight his
power everything translate better to
head heavyweight like he you
ran through people in strike he did like
he's never lost that heavyweight where
he belongs
I agree respect the king I mean I don't
Cana his in his prime
I would love to seen that fight I've
seen that fight yeah but he's used to
drag him because no McCain went to him
for the Olympic wrestling training right
right right so this is where he belongs
he's not going back down they're gonna
strip him of the belt that's that and we
will enough alone shut up Christmas
bones young nose candy hey meet you cuz
your face looks crazy familiar New York
I'll tell you what you want to hear but
what you need to hear so yeah man I got
so much real life stuff going on not a
lot of gaming unfortunately so King you
could put the fraud report on me
I have no big story but I want to
finally got home ordered my new PC rig
so hockey busting recommendations crazy
no I know y'all want to get what is it
20 80 in oil at nah man
I'm not really trying to use it as a
gaming cracy I wanted to go like CPU
heavy I'm not but I just got like a test
I see this I'm doing the double spoon
for you guys it was running off a really
old game so I'll be jumping in and the
master race and then shout out as soon
as I did it
shout out there or was it Blizzard
making the free destiny to claim a
feeling me right back about his not
banded in my console crew but it's just
funny teasing them Sancho right
technically you can still be in the
party because Microsoft allows you to
still you know party chat and you can
over there you know cuz Microsoft does
that that is true we shall see also I
wanted to on announce real quick
obviously you know Slava you gonna do
your bank or budget after estate and
around that time once again ladies and
gents today's palms have been greased
dispense it's time to say thank you to
our patreon subscribers as we always do
every month as I said last week guys if
you go to the patreon now a lot of the
language has been changed simply because
patreon is trying to get away from
language that talks about any sort of
giveaways anything like that so it's
kind of hard to determine like what's
the difference in tears so just know
that everything that we had in place
before is still there the ten dollar
giveaway is twenty dollar giveaway is
t-shirts and the vibe monthly game
giveaway it's all still there
we just can't write it that way anymore
so till we figure out another way to
word the stuff
and we go have back and forth with their
um with their sort of customer service
to figure out how to do it it's just
gone so but just understand that it's
all still there still still happening so
yeah so let's go through just giving
thanks to all you guys have been
supporting us we really appreciate it
you know that trying to do different and
bigger things every single month so um
again thank you for your support so
let's start off with Lord whisky himself
Cory lighting thank you so much my
brother
whisky the building I hope you family
and we got the PlayStation brah thank
you brah then we have Lord Kareem H aka
comm masters thank you so much for your
support brother appreciate it
Lord Fastback himself Thank You Man
thank you thank you so much for
everything
I know g-man I was up on any show that
great show man Friday show me wild love
y'all then we have Lord Michael Liu go
monkey punch himself but uh thank you my
brother
mm-hmm the lord of back compat bills
still well some day one thank you so
much for the support always love with
the great wall lord two's AKA Ricky
Moore jr. thank you my brother much
appreciated yeah I love a support mm-hmm
Lord spoon man another man from day one
day one always say with the Lord's thank
you so much for the support rider die
right there shouts boo me my fellow
vanderlin gang member a Fonzarelli thank
his Red Dead review coming soon not a
day hey you go thank you king of the
stream team and the gleam master Lord
Snell doe himself you guys feeding a
building in the building thank you for
the love and help brother he is he's on
it they absolutely just indispensable
health to thy Lord sit around and we go
Lord loaded pig
so I heard you sir Kabira thank you very
much for the support course Lord cat
daddy building the chat beloved when
he's in the chat I know it's not easy
he's in the chat man from Portugal
singer one we said he bribed you this
mostly no I'm sorry I'm talking about I
jump somebody that's Inca thank you my
brother you Lord still killer Diago
Padre thank you my brother
mean of course last and certainly not
least the lord of coating himself
optimus cold OG that's always reppin OG
thank you bro thank you for the support
we ring you she in the realm thank you
guys for all the support as always we
truly appreciate it mom so let's get
into these different ways so there's no
game giveaway this month that'll be next
month getting ready for that uh so you
know start picking out what you want to
get so let's start off with this $10
give away right so the $10 gift card
goes Lord optimist Cole I go fantastic
okay yes okay yes sir what do you say
triple og after yes look at that it goes
with your og optimist facts alright so
now let's get into this $20 code and
that goes to load it takes those yeah
that the palms the greased Meno this
this is old-school love you know saying
no palm Greeson needed
and there we go closes the lick
therefore grave oh yeah mmm now let's
get into this t-shirt giveaway right oh
and actually we're getting two t-shirts
because I forgot big shout-out to Lord
spoon man from last month forward his
t-shirt and anyway lord thank you lord
you know I can't wear red out here I'm
done Lord cat daddy who has like a
million you got these prizes but if
there's only the same people in the
picture we can't expect about this but
as you don't have a huge number of
patrons so certain your names will come
up twice keep showing up in the chat
like we can't win you can win because
these do they have it they're like no
patrons we're gonna clean house every I
say he's not giving back nothing he's
one for every day the man that is that
for this month once again thank you for
all the support guys we truly appreciate
it
especially with these you know these
moves that we've been making lately
things changing a little bit every
little bit helps thank you so much for
the support and we got more things
coming obviously you know we're already
looking down the road we looking at
packs looking at e3 this thing's coming
check out the teespring stuff we got
some new lines coming got some new
colors they're already Thanksgiving
colors green the people been asking for
and all that could not happen without
support from you guys so thank you so
much music the link is in the
description or the iron Lords shop get
that more swag like I was saying also
just real quick announcers we got again
so shall we take a long time yo what I'm
gonna say is Lords obviously you know
how
coming up and we trying to do more
giveaway so we are going to announce
state of the realm announcement freshman
ILP the latest giveaway I'm gonna throw
it up in the chat right now boom that
smash bros ultimate is yo y'all make
sure you into the giveaway and you're
trying to give this thing away it's
gonna be a digital copy on Fortune's
gonna be us only on everyone but it will
be us only because the thing is all of
these consoles are pretty much region
free but when it comes to digital codes
the codes are usually region locked so
it's if I we sent you a disk which is
just a pain in the rear you can play it
on pretty much any console same for
Nintendo or cartridge whatever just
digital codes are region-locked and that
becomes a problem well what I want y'all
to do this I want you to do this like if
you guys are and I'm gonna show you I'm
give you hustle I'm giving game right
now this is gay this is gay I'm giving
you game if you what is it how game ship
with somebody kick them off right now
go gam share with somebody in the United
States right and you have the cold the
cold you have their night stage you put
code and boom bang you want them
together look you contributed to his get
a stack y'all good you're playing a new
game is the smash brothers its own game
share share with them they want you to
send your first tooth it came out your
mouth when you was a baby they want that
too they want a couple of more DNA
samples instead of smooth sampling maybe
yo shout the hex you say we Salvage is
before all its giveaways lock for 11
minutes it started you could blame law
senado for that take all your complaints
the loss now you know somebody just told
you his cookies not a block absolutely
so yeah again thank you guys for
supporting us like I said we've been
trying to do more with the giveaways
more a charm please if you haven't
signed up even if it's just a buck man
get in there get these shirts get these
things we got stuff to give away the
part of the ILP paints not so soft the
Proms can be grazed and he can come so
you just said a buck right this is this
bro boom mind blown right walk away you
see these guys getting t-shirts right
put the dialogue bone walk away if you
don't win for 20 months description yeah
get in there man we got some cool so we
gonna get it to the show man we runnin
late like crazy but uh yeah that's what
we got you know saying that was thing so
um obviously you know we got the Lords
in in in brown and our glob oh he has
already received the deep-fryer
treatment he's been in the round before
so make sure you guys check out I'll be
42 Calabro has a tremendous history and
impressive gaming history so what you
just well know what latest was been
going on into dalabo with your channel
and stuff like that I know you've been
mi a little bit so and then also I
wanted to know just a revised real quick
if you have any revisions to your top 5
so just a short little run-through just
get everybody up speed yeah yeah so um
recently we added a new segment to the
channel and call hero unlock basically
every week what we do is we pick one
protagonist and we just highlight their
development their lore and their legacy
within gaming and so what I mean you
know there's been other channels that
did that before so it was like what do
we do when we do do you know make that
unique so we decided not only we're
gonna add our brand of you know humor to
obviously you know we're gonna we're
gonna do little little segments within
it to help break it up you know a little
interviews or do jokes and actually
bring in people who don't really know
that much about gaming and me we like we
make sure that you know they leave leave
themselves a little more educated about
you know what's going on in the gaming
space especially with that particular
character so it's really cool
interacting with all these different
kinds of people and that kind of thing
and it fits into my major and so like
I've been trying to you know with
everything I'm trying to get better at
editing and everything that's going on
with it so love the new series bubble
you guys gotta check it out - have a
great one up right now like they did
they did I believe you didn't Laura
Croft you did a Pokemon one we've got
some great protagonists that you guys
and in deep dive with it video
production is very high quality
as usual good to see that activity and I
just wanted to since you came back maybe
did top 5 with you last time but any any
changes to that list as everything
remains absolutely it's so weird to
think that like I just like I was asleep
on this franchise for so long and so I
popped in old blood because you know I
wanted to go in order and my goodness
just BJ baskets is one of the best
heroes I've ever ever because like the
great thing about old blood is that in
that particular one
BJ doesn't talk a lot but when he does
it's just profound poetic just stuff
like riffing off his head and it's it's
it feels so natural feels because like
as somebody who's a military you know
person we oftentimes we don't think
these characters have been like video
games movies have any like internal
struggle or anything like that they're
just like shoot kill whatever like that
and it's it's just so refreshing to see
character like this the acting is
fantastic the story structure the game
kicks your butt it's just it's
it's it's just it's overall just a
fantastic series of games and I am so
close to finishing Wolfenstein 2 and
every time a new chapter opens I'm just
surprised it's just constant shock
warned me about that yet I'm so excited
for that
all right so I understand I understand
the Capcom doesn't hit everybody it's
not for everyone and then four would be
pokemon crystal because I mean my my age
group when I mean Pokemon was so crazy I
just thinking back to all of it was wild
3 is gonna be League of Legends I put in
so many hours in that I don't want to
tell people how many hours I put it like
it's you know it's just one of those
like it's it's borderline addicting it's
wild it's well so Wolfenstein I'm
actually putting it to because I I'm
just sound like when I do a hero unlock
on BJ blaskowitz that that one's gonna
be the ball baby hurt yeah he's a huge
BJ face so yo check that out it's
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
the top one for me is it's always always
gonna be breath of the wild and the
reason why like even you guys were
talking about red dead in the world and
everything like that you were talking
about like all the crazy things that
just kept on bringing up things from
when I remember when breath of the wild
launched it's exactly the same thing and
that's like no you created a great world
because people can discover things and
talk about things like oh did you get to
this part of this crazy thing happen
have you tried this try this is that the
kind of discussion about a great open
world I'm telling you it's just this
this game is gonna be really hard to
talk to me especially for when it comes
to Zelda haven't seen you in a while so
I always try to ask when you come back
yeah yeah Lourdes meds
you know you have known in many gaming
podcast circles and obviously you are yo
make sure you got following it's a
fantastic follow on Twitter not just for
gaming but also MMA as well fons you
need to be fine well so won't you tell
don't run a little bit about yourself
and like just what got you into gaming
and also by fellow NYC graduate what's
up you know what man when I was a little
kid I got a Super Nintendo Donkey Kong
Country let's go I beat that game like
50 times I was poor I was mad for dude
that's the one game I had bro what you
broke that game I know every secret
drugs KZ uh you know then Tendo stuff
kid you know I came up with a PC gaming
now
yeah hmm and you know I love it you know
I still play consoles and stuff like
that I love my switch you know nothing I
don't agree with King these dudes here
see what you don't get right now yeah
and I notice now that you're here you
probably do get it I'm against all use
right so I see you I see youse guys my
back is against the wall my TV and it's
so rough for a while at the bottom I see
you fraud and King you know perfect
potentially knows I got all those
amiibos in there I'm probably the
biggest switch and does I probably kept
them afloat for a couple of months all
right they know how it goes I just want
original content I don't I supported do
we you brought all those games already
all right I don't want I want new stuff
so for y'all y'all didn't support the
Wii U so y'all got you get back in there
no it's not that you back in I've never
lost afraid so
when when you never leave if somebody
keeps giving you the same Turkey and
mashed potatoes and Turkey much tennis
you've never sat at this table you sit
down you let your heart be restless good
right so yo you got eat this up and I'm
like I've been eating turkey and mashed
potatoes for the last seven years bro I
don't know turkey and mashed potatoes
sorry
[Laughter]
and nothing to do with his knees but
real quick Nizam I need cause your
guests here always ask every guest in
row yeah video game franchise and I know
top five
[Laughter]
Final Fantasy franchise street fighter
franchise Oh Mario Kart franchise okay
let's see mmm that's rough
I study here at Donkey Kong I'm kind of
disappointed Donkey Kong it kind of fell
off by the way
the best emi played this year though
facts years ago and the greatest
franchise of all time
come at me good yes combat talk but I
wasn't jumping in we go so on yo last
week's poll results are in and the
people have spoken to the question with
the technical breakdowns and rave
reviews by various media outlets
regarding Red Dead Redemption - on the
Xbox one X is this now the definitive
reason to own or purchase the X the
women or the commanding 75% of the vote
is the yes the X is the best place to
play multiplex group coming in at second
at only 20 percent of the vote no I joke
a one-game doesn't justify purchasing an
X any last place or shallows have father
said I don't care 864 P on s is the
place for me group last week's poll Lord
Galaga Lord met I need your opinion
does read their justify another reason
to get a xbox one X not at that price
point nope I'm sorry hit me a bundle
like baby the way I would say it is
Red Deer justifies buying I mean read
their justifies buying that on the X but
it isn't just by buying an X catch you
Lord de la Co ya know that's that's
that's pretty much I can't I can't do it
for a game just one game saying I just
bought that one game the Pope actually
did check the box and he say yes you
should so I are here for the big one we
got some new tenants in the building so
smash bros direct went down now what's
going on and just want to talk about
that brunette to the roundtable
obviously they announced the ultimate
adventure mode looks like a smash bros
infinity war people are getting all
sucked away it was crazy like so yeah
that you got you know we had a whole
bunch of features i just want to briefly
just go over a few was the key stand out
to me um obviously they had to play at
color
so when playing smash online to players
can't eat oh like that for a couple
Super Smash Brothers hasn't news this is
the new yeah man did he have obviously
the elite smash mole they had the
background matchmaking grandpa getting
his match make
Oh 20:18 like one thing I wanna like
point out is why this games like this
get an online multiplayer games like
Mario Party don't like it's like it's
like they have their foot half in and
half out just be saved that dog's videos
did like so basically you could play up
things while you're waiting in the lobby
Tekken all these games but that's cool
and then um you've got our battle arenas
you know you have to custom cut battle
arenas with your people you can get that
going on and one of the features I
thought was interesting new smartphone
features Tendo and their apps it dropped
the new one so eggplants have that voice
chat to use with others in Rena's the
mobile service I believe is called smash
world it's be developed so it's not even
finished in develop was that obviously
that they will be needing a fighters
season so through characters one stage
each with his own stage and bad stuff
music we don't know who the characters
are but it's gonna be $25 reported that
out ready for that it did yeah you can
buy each individually for $6 and by the
way like Lord addict said for those who
get that little pre-order that
post-launch bonus will be the piranha
plant so tons of smash news to get into
oh I want your feeling on the direct how
feel about it and then on and DLC model
the okay so overall I think this is
probably turning out to be one of the
greatest values in gaming just as far as
the characters content you're getting
we're talking about the music the stages
the characters all of that you don't get
in I'm just saying you don't get this in
any other fighting game
I feel like you have to keep saying I'm
just saying PLC and some of them also
have DLC that they announce right then I
don't I don't play a traffic tracking I
don't I'm gonna call track I don't play
that
I don't play Tekken like yeah and in
Soul Calibur just had this issue they
were announcing DLC characters before
the game even launched like these
characters were done lately right all
you guys are suffer probably addict um
come from buying the cartridge and
everything is on the cartridge and if
they wanted to you know like because you
you you actually came into the digital
age where DLC was more acceptable like
alright so okay let me include you into
this alright even though I'm on the
thing is would not actually be a little
bit happier if they decided to start
charging a hundred dollars for the game
and all the DLC is everything is there
just just just just beat me one time for
the game don't beat me repeatedly over a
period of years just just give me
everything all in one shot and leave me
the hell alone and stop digging in my
wallet type of thing um I'm at the point
where I'm sick and tired of cuz I
finished the spider-man DLC and I'm like
man you know what you guys could
actually just put it all in one package
and allow me to
Paquette at my leisure for the 89.95
leave me alone the past included priced
from no I know I don't want no season I
want that season pasture I want that DLC
stuff then this is stuff this is content
that they didn't say all your again was
finished we sat back and we delivered we
know this is premeditated murder then
they doing on your wallet no like daddy
said announced in DLC before the game
launches sucks dummies just said that's
the way they do things now when it comes
to like they want to keep their game in
the public conscience for as long as
possible if you get all that stuff up
front if you're hardcore you're gonna
blaze out that game for a month or two
and then move on if you're not your
casual you still pay that money you'll
play it for a couple of weeks tops and
then it's done with you're not thinking
about it again but if they tell you
that's gonna be DLC and molds and
whatever coming down two months down the
line it still stays in your mind like
okay you know if people were talking
about it again mm-hmm gives you one shot
that's that mmm I shot the anchor he
said they already do that King it's
called the Ultimate editions buddy I
don't think he's getting fundamentally
what the hell I'm talking about because
I'm not talking about an ultimate
edition but I'm talking about the game
no more for $60 hmm all right stop - $60
correct because the game is at $60 and I
know you're sitting there saying and
well it's ala carte you don't have to
purchase it but they want you to and if
they they're afraid to tell you 89.95
they're free to stay 89.95 what a price
of the game market has remained stagnant
write it in defense of these companies
right you know these games are not
getting any cheaper so we know that for
the most part $60 you know it not moving
from that point it's tough you know
saying it's it's over cause I'm not
trying to justify I'm just saying like
they you know ways to try to monetize
and to get more money oh this is what
I'm staying Cognito right make better
games right but all right
ready let's get ready for instance
millions of you guys was ready to snap
that credit card to put that in right
now let them s say well Red Dead is
89.95 all that extra stuff they're
supposed to be in every DLC every
everything is in there it's already in
there
got it we're not gonna come into your
wallet anymore I don't think the people
would have backed away from that I think
actually people just know what what
you're saying that as the only option
like that oh yeah that would have been
the game to do it cuz I think that's
what I think that's what at what anchors
talking about that they giving you all
these options at Long's okay if you
don't want that here's the $70 version
here's the hundred oh no don't do
different versions I mean at least
there's some for some games there's some
options right there like there's some
games that do that it's like okay you
can get the ultimate edition you know
whatever
that's neat season pass or whatever you
have all the DLC whatever whatever or
you know you just get the base game but
I want to shout out what I miss inside
like nobody's really talking about
inflation right that these games like it
can six people for the longest you know
say that for something like they got it
Trotta and you know the cost of
development and got let's get back to
the lava because I wanted to get him
he's off someone else masking bike back
to the hole reveal like how did you feel
with everything like well if you if you
were following if you were following it
before the direct happened there was a
there was like a notorious leak that
happened and and whenever there's a
major leak about Smash Bros people get
you know they they get their
expectations right stupid super high and
so personally for me I don't I don't
subscribe to any of those leaves I I
take them all as fake until I see
actually like Nintendo confirm it so
when I got there you know they're the
bustin out with Ken you know and it's in
Aurora I'm like okay this is this is
great now we now have 74 fighters you
know and a piranha plant a plant yeah
and and you know I I at the end of the
day I'm very I'm still excited as I was
when they first announced it because
just the idea that they go we have so
many characters we have so much to do in
this game there's so much to unlock
there's so much to still see in here and
experience and smash Moses is one of
those games it like when you get your
people together in one room to play that
game moments happen like magical moments
happen and that's just what smash bros
is and that's what it will always
continue to be granted I don't know how
they'll ever top this
there's another one I think they might
have already they might have set the bar
a little too high for themselves with
this one but I just need I need my man
to get some rest
let's talk about that cuz site is that
I'm this video look like a saccharide
snuff video like he looked he looked
like he had Reggie on one side and
miyamoto on the other side with guns to
his head he looked dead tired like and
it's just like one of those things this
is this is a pre-recorded thing when you
have an awkward silence
and something's reported why didn't they
edit that out like he just looked like
he was uncomfortable being you just on
it will they change the text and he was
like damage ah I three or DLC can go
game you did it to yourself and it's
like whoa I almost what about when he
said ah when will I ever get some rest
that was just a weird humor that the
Japanese culture has like if you watch
any other stuff they try to put that in
and it just goes for so doesn't feel
natural there was plenty of that
but saccharide like notoriously been
overworked when it comes to this
remember he said he wasn't doing this
one and actually he I think he said he
wasn't doing the wheel with the way you
want either and then I feel like ain't
nobody boycotting this game because he
working hundred plus hours oh you know
how it goes they the tree house they did
not know leaves coming out of the tree
house my man Jose Otero went to work for
Nintendo you only hear from him on
holidays when you know oh yeah
they have him chained to the tree so
[Laughter]
meds what about you man did you see the
direct
they pretty much like prepare everyone
they're like this is all about smash
don't come in here expecting incoming
nonsense Oh coming here expecting any
metro cities are about smash you have
extra switch for a long time you are
like eight men who are people who have
just been waiting for this game
so with this reveal did it meet your
expectations were you pumped up like yo
I'll be good Super Smash Brothers it's
always been a girl you know franchise
that I play I remember playing the ODA
the very first one in the n64 when you
just had like six eight characters it's
I really like that they're doing a lot
of fan service when it comes to this for
instance the original roster that you
get from the start is is literally the
n64 roster and you keep going in from
there so you're pretty much unlocking
them though in the order you unlock them
throughout the whole franchise hmm so I
think that's cool this story seems
generic but that that's just about every
other Smash Bros infinity war with a
wiping everybody is hell with all the
little hands
d-dude Corby was gonna make it out of it
screw tech did a death battle between
Kirby and margin booth someone from a
universe that blows up planets and
universities and Kirby beat him like in
pure streams
you know margin boom beats him at every
angle but Kirby is so like this he's not
he's literally indestructible yeah
especially the Goku of the Dead they had
to tune him down in Smash Brothers
because he was - Oh Pete - okay he's all
he almost in every tournament space
every kind of format Connelly in the top
three every time yeah that's crazy so
overall you were satisfied which since
they told me the roster at the end of
the day this game you know I understand
people were like oh but this is back
when they announced that all you know
they only have these I was kind of
surprised it's only five characters that
I have them for the expansion because I
feel like when it comes to this certain
thing they can literally keep giving us
a game over there characters every other
month - people would buy oh yeah
absolutely so they only have five the -
controversial things I want to ask
before we move on everybody else about
the new app that's being released for
voice chat and about the DLC model do
you have any issues with any of those -
I got this core don't need none with
what I understand why they did the I
think that there should have been a way
to do it naturally on the console I
don't think they were really cared looks
like it won't see their their standpoint
is they're really focused and everything
Jay Tendo does is really focused on on
Japan like that Oh
what's going on they made it for Japan
because that's that's where they make
these consoles for like they make it for
Japan and they export them out that's
why you know there but my thing is what
about another thing coming in this and
I'm glad that uh what you call it a
shout out to your hands l brought it up
a lot of people coming in said hey we
thought banjo would get it now right
but it was a big represent did you think
it was happening I remember you know we
thought there might be some cross thing
going on Microsoft was pissed I think
that might be one of those five
characters I never thought is gonna be
announced today because I've had a
feeling that was DLC because that's how
they're going to convince you know
Microsoft to letting them use that IP is
like you can have a percentage of the
DLC - ooh yeah so you overall you're
good Lord soft and then King I mean I
agree with the labo like this this has
so much stuff in it and it's coming out
like usually December releases are in
the bushes and that's for that's
reserved for games to go and die after
anything that comes out of the Black
Friday but with this game like it's so
it's kind of perfect for this time of
year because it's just it's pure
Nintendo love and even for kids that
don't know anything about these
franchises in particular whatever once
you see Mario won't you see Kirby that
just it moves units listen
my five-year-old nephew he was Mariel
this year for um for Halloween and his
only his only knowledge of Mario is
Super Mario run
Super Mario on the SNES classic and the
old Mario cartoons that I think they
have them streaming either on Prime's
right so here's the old marrow cartoons
like captain Lou albano and stuff that's
if that if his love of Mario stems from
that if he sees a game with all of these
characters and Mario be on this one at
that point it's gonna to me it's gonna
sell gangbusters more I don't even think
it's a like a question that this games
not gonna do numbers like you this game
more than usual cuz I know earlier when
we talked about it coming out the end of
the year this was in a past show and we
talked about it in relation to Pokemon
you still kind of thought maybe Pokemon
would do better because smash is still o
it just feels like they're the old line
is gonna do better than what still gonna
be better yeah but I think smash is
gonna surprise and no I don't like it's
gonna surprise it's gonna do numbers but
I guarantee at the end of this Pokemon
scroll gonna do anywhere from eight
million to 15 million ever bet against
Pokemon and all honesty this is the pole
so what do you want to consider beating
Pokemon six months I want you to walk to
the camera don't do it bro both copies
both versions a game every time so to
that point like what is the difference
besides it's just Evie Evie and Pikachu
Pikachu let's go
gonna be trashed compared to one that
comes out next year in version of the
game they they lock different pokemons
behind each version so you have to trade
with other people it was it was
initially intended to encourage trading
but what happened is people were like I
think that was the original intent that
they wanted to the original one was they
wanted to you know get people to start
talking to each other and you know
trading but then they're like you know
people really buying both of them since
I was a child always been like the games
were released in two in twos and pears
and then what I happen every once in a
while is already so third version that's
like a I guess like a celebration of all
of them but a lot of missing Pokemon so
does it right yellow that was the third
for Bloomberg red then they have pokemon
crystal that was the third for silver
and gold and then they kind of went away
from that until pokemon platinum not
platinum was the only game in the whole
franchise that had all the pokemon in
one game mm-hm
now they did emerald two for the
generation about it as well right now
Cognito is looking like it out there's
ice this is what they do to get those
nothing when I go buy Pokemon right and
I buy it for my son on on the 3ds when I
go buy Pokemon I gotta buy the the Sun
and the moon I gotta buy just buy in
Ruby I got a BA I have to buy each each
one you know because he's not really out
here running in these streets talking to
people Pokemon right I definitely need
to make sure that he you know has good
he will tell you I don't have all the
pokemon daddy T not in here I'm black
he has beaten you into submission so
addict was gonna go that way the
dinosaur talking about the smash watch I
swore I thought he was talking about
smash brothers I said listen I know for
a fact they already got four copies for
me coming y'all to yo know but y'all two
is gonna have two copies younger here
but uh oh wow
Pokemon is inside the one pack is not
trust me that's how you got is now
what's right is more for the casual know
it's there it's there tempt to make
Pokemon go relevant again okay and I
feel like they're sacrificing these two
games to do that now it's gonna sell
well the core mechanics I'm a Pokemon
Pokemon they're not in this game for a
person like me to noob the Freud of
Pokemon like oh you love me that's what
I'm saying this is for me then they come
from they are yeah saying like that's
good if it'll get you into Pokemon and
that kind of thing and make it the
numbers the next game or even bigger
because you know you have that renewed
interest or you have that new interest
Pokemon you know what's funny if the
cells on this if it's a lot lower than
we think and they don't release the next
Pokemon games for that's great they're
like you know no one buys it let's just
go back to the handheld market look my
worry is that it sells so well but they
connects Pokemon
nobody by this I don't want I don't mind
the Pokemon go interact interactions I
just want it to be optional because it
feels like a lot of the time like
they're making this like something you
have to do mmm like they don't act like
this is something that's option or
they're like maybe when they were
showing me like it thank God that
Nintendo there's a reason Nintendo flag
my stuff down when I was doing the
library action disgusted they said how
how that you have to use that pokeball
thing or it can you just know but you
have to use the sensor on the controller
to do anything you can't Eve use a pro
controller it's not even compatible with
it you gonna use it this way this way
only I love that I love that because
they're just testing your resolve I love
that taken away your option because the
pokeball comes with Mewtwo so like I'm
gonna move over stop me
basically I'm surprised that job I mean
it's just me like as far as the one
point as far as the DLC bottle like how
is it my feelings about that like Oh
Sakura came out said yeah we're not
telling you what's in it but it's gonna
be hot and I'm like why am I supposed to
have confidence in you yeah most people
want banjo or something like I wasn't
feeling they throughout that plant
character and I'm supposed to be popping
bottles no that's not a go second you're
gonna get a gig I think okay one I've
been this has been done to me by
Bethesda body with the tiki torches on
this but i'ma tell you dis those kognito
I think the ink is not dry yet on some
of those characters okay yeah that made
us
that's because if they know they're
gonna have five they probably have a
backup five and the five they want but
they're not gonna tell you the five that
they want unless they can get the
signatures down so maybe banjo is in
there but Microsoft is saying okay well
we want this if you want that you know
type of thing and they trying to figure
if that's gonna work and then what other
characters in there that they're trying
to get the licensing for I honestly
believe it's dead some of these trophy
characters to man like a a killer from
from like Virtua Fighter like make
Virtua Fighter characters actual
fighters in the game I saw a lot of
backlash with some of the characters
that were kind of what is it relegated
to the spirit ball and then obviously
shot I mentioned before I stick a big
was it what I mean so um you know very
crucial there but again I was just a
little frustrating but overall for the
for the value of what you're getting in
the base that is a lot of characters I
like the old-school approach when you
unlock everything I like that I like the
world oh yeah ice pour it and say I was
immediately overwhelmed can i oh
Platinum is definitely standalone it
came two years after Diamond and Pearl
go look at all but it's not we'll have a
myth we'll have a myth are you saying
that platinum came out they all came out
after yellow didn't come out with red
and blue same team crystal they all came
after they were all after like a year or
so actually I think yellow came out
later that year though oh yeah yours
already four abandon me goodie out here
he said you have more it try to get some
knees right now I don't know
Aegina wait a month he tried to get you
sick knees the other day feature-rich
the game looks amazing crazy onions of
things to do I like that story mode this
thing's gonna smell like hotcakes it's
just at the end of the day in the last
but the last thing though it this
smartphone app in the bushes come on
don't make a second app after no one's
feeling the first finish out okay when
are we gonna just acknowledge and we
have acknowledged elephant evil and
y'all suckers y'all freud's in a city
and state its nitendo be Nintendo this
is my kids this year for Halloween war
my my two daughters with Mario and Luigi
alright so I understand they there's an
affinity isn't a law is its y'all got
this thing over your eyes like it's
really a veil that is keeping you from
seeing the real world now these dudes
hit you in the head with this fake
online at crap before that's my other
thing is like personally I don't know
anyone who uses it on a regular basis
out of except for anything like if they
play splatoon a lot they get special
items in splatoon that's pretty much it
but like no one no one I know is using
it that's funny something a male about
getting some free if I use it or some
switch
in these gaming streets it's a bit much
but the other day game looks good most
people don't buy it
it doesn't matter lot of stuff to do but
we are going to move on Lord
Red Dead issues what's up oh we actually
oh you know we had the guest and I think
Finn thing is mine it's very small and
I'm just really going that J fons really
Nick these are a bug in there in the
game there's a lot of bugs in the game
and for them to be gaming a year you
can't have a bug of this magnitude me
mmm in my opinion from that if you do a
certain thing and I don't want to talk
about it because a lot of guys don't
have the game or just got the game and
they trying to get around to it if you
do a out of order if you go to a town
out of order and knocks the sequins off
of the game and four characters
disappear from that storyline that you
need in the game hmm
to progress at a certain point and essa
is a bug that they're trying to work out
now now my thing is I know I didn't
preface it properly but can a game with
that type of bug game of the year can it
even be considered game of the year when
you didn't test for that type of bug I
can see if you say sheep flying over a
cliff or something you know you see that
bug but are you talking about a bug
where four main NPCs disappear from a
storyline that you need to progress in
the storyline that's kind of not
acceptable
mmm interesting and I want to double
down on it because shelter the skunk ass
if
tastic episode yesterday and I brought
this to their attention in reference to
you know even Ramzan yet we talked about
you know the perfect gate right and when
a game gets a 10 and media outlets and
things like that so obviously kings
bringing up the bugs you know another
thing we talked about fix your face off
I know you upset when I'm talk you know
the control you know saying and
obviously you know the people I have
some gripes with it they feel it's a bit
archaic read you know that uh Rockstar
has an updated stuff obviously me an
addict have talked about this last aisle
piece I want to bring it to the two
guests in the realm Lord the labo first
arm what do you feel about being with
maybe some minor flaws or an issue is
that still considered a ten or is it
more of like hey it's still a fantastic
game of the generation regardless of
these minor things well I've been saying
it for a long time with game reviews in
how that goes that build quality isn't
one of the factors that a lot of them go
into and so what happens is I mean I
knew I knew this game was gonna have
bugs
it's a massive world it's a lot of
things interacting with other things
it's gonna have bugs however a story
based bug or something like that what
that's being described that is
unacceptable
then I mean why why did the play set the
play test you can catch this like that's
that's just well to me um now because
that can severely cut someone's
enjoyment of the game I don't I don't I
don't know I don't know if that can be a
bat can still retain game of the year um
if you just like just destroys your
progress within the game the goods adds
on that's just I'm sorry that's it
that's unacceptable so basically now a
game working bug kind of puts that off
your list
absolutely okay okay solutely and what
now what if that let's let me flip it
the other way what if that bug didn't
exist right and it was just you know you
just maybe silo of gripes with the
control just minor stuff if it was just
what that if that aspect was the only
aspect would that detract or that
wouldn't affect her right when we when
we give games attend or whatever because
obviously a game of the air can only
like I'm a like a 10 out of 10 you know
kind of pain when we give a game a score
like that we know that there it's gonna
have faults right there's no there's no
such thing as a perfect game because it
fundamentally cannot exist that's not so
they're gonna be faulted in it there's
gonna be things you don't like it's
gonna be quarks there's gonna be yes
there's gonna be bugs but at the end of
the day the game as a whole has to be
able to surpass all those things and
make those negligible in our mindset so
when you have a game breaking bugs like
that that's always gonna be at your back
of your mind that's always gonna be why
I had to start over to surpass this this
giant bug I did all this progress I'm
after yeah so it's at that frustration
that annoyance and that's ultimately
that's gonna ruin it for me someone like
me enough Lord makes what do you feel on
the the idea of a perfect game any flaw
or you know if something is truly
spectacular for a generation does it
overlook that I mean all these games
that get you know tens and all that
they've you know those flaws have
already been overlooked otherwise it
would gonna get that but I understand
that 10 doesn't mean perfect so there's
no I think when people say oh it's a
tenant's not perfect I mean yeah they
can both be true got you fair enough
fair enough
Lord sob seething in the corner hey
listen I know full well that that's why
I don't like dealing with with tens and
numbers everything is subjective what I
consider to be great someone else may
not consider be great and I respect that
um so this type of bug though is is
tough because what it
the story is so integral to what Red
Dead is that if you're talking about
missing out on missions that could
potentially also teach you a game
mechanic that you don't you're not able
to learn before that they tied it to a
story mission so if something happens
and you run into this bug you may not
learn how to fish and in fishing is a is
a sort of a big part of some of the
open-world stuff so it's like okay that
needs to be addressed immediately before
they HDR stuff before anything else and
if you notice like I talked about last
week like rock star doesn't care like
you
you don't see Rockstar having like this
uh like like a community person up like
they're listening to everything you say
they're not responding and they're gonna
work on it at the pace that they're
gonna work on it and obviously this is
huge so I'm assuming this is something
that's at the forefront of what they
need to get rectified but you know
there's no communication back and forth
between the mean that you know away from
from what I feel is like an absolutely
amazing game know that said if I ran
into it myself I'd have a problem I've
got you so let me ask you sell the ball
a hundred I'll workweek and she added
two more hours but considering
considering the scope of this game the
amount of other smaller bugs that it has
all kind of remarkably low like this
crazy like if you look at like okay
fallout anchor you're gonna hate me but
the fallout recently had the most epic
of bugs ever where it deleted the entire
beta from your computer with something I
was yeah yeah I mean listen J Street
he's like look man sees me more people
oppressed by the realism and detail the
graphics he said oh I'm dizzy made a
good point he was just talked about they
released a statement and at the end of
the day he said it doesn't break the
game though he said it doesn't affect
the main story room standing it's still
cool but you know he it's not game
breaking that if it folds the game for
you but what happens is that some of the
main characters some of the characters
that have big roles in the game later on
are not there for the most part of
chapter two and then they just jump back
that's not that's to me
listen I'm I'm so into trying to do
everything in that game like every
little thing side stuff whatever to miss
something like that it would piss me off
big time no addict you gonna double down
on your position you talk about are you
good he's in the bushes before
you know like stop said this thing is
very subjective you know at the end of
the day you know it's what the game
meant to you you know and how much of
that does it affect you you know I agree
there is no probably no perfect game but
I do struggle with ten's being handed
out like it's candy and you know my
whole thing is you know King weed from
that era like James didn't get it in
like it was very rare so it's like you
know obviously when I see ten know those
type of things and influence me to buy
the game and then unfortunately went
because I've seen - it makes me look at
the game more with a critical eye yeah
it's subjective it's gonna come down to
you know what that experience did for
you and also I also feel some of these
games that are getting tens are also
reflection of the timepiece when it
dropped because that particular game was
doing something that no other game at
that moment was doing so like it kind of
changed it so that's why I just did
passes for stuff like that we go move on
I don't want to say one thing just you
know I'll close it um I don't want to
say because it changed the change from
it changed from the bug to us
questioning if it's a ten for some
people anybody you know some some guys
might have that thing as a tendon that's
just cool and we in a different way in a
hot / billy time right so where people
want to get on a pylon and start to
train them and they like the likes
and that's like hey we all that was my
thing is should it be removed at a game
of the year contention for a bug of that
magnitude to remove intrical characters
from a storyline game like sovereign
said and that was enough for me
mmm and him saying if he had encountered
that and it would be that would have
soured him to the point dad
well I'm sorry I had an emergency happen
over here what kind of bug are we
referring to let me tell you real quick
all right is a bug inside the game if
you go to a certain location before you
go to another location I can't I don't
want to say it because I want them to
experience it and I want them to be
pissed off and characters are emitted
from the storyline that will they you
won't see them they won't be present and
they they're needed to progress in at
that certain storyline and then it will
pop up like sovereign said after that
chapter is over with that part there all
that dialogue all that story gone so you
miss a large part of that storyline that
that little arc and what I'm saying is
let's say if you was playing God of War
and that little gnome dude wasn't there
and he had told you a whole big story
that you were supposed to get right
there but because you went to the lake
and drink that water first and you go to
him he's not there and then he pops up
later on he's telling you something else
that you have no idea what the hell he's
talking about
did you miss this in a story-based kid
does that knock it out a game in the
year contention that you're saying is
there is a glitch in the game tour if
you go to a certain point it's it's
start it pretty much four starts the
game from that point on and it misses
everything prior to that it misses that
story arc yet for four characters
completely disappear I feel like this
camp game can't be Game of the Year
trolls like the game that forces you to
use auto aim in Auto is like how long I
don't use a lot of horror sis you just
gotta get good
you just gotta I don't believe that he's
like um he doesn't know like what red
daddy's doing anything else is it is
that is that shade is that is that like
you don't feel it's like the the
greatest one of the tax rate on that I
mean I literally had someone in this and
someone in this community not gonna say
names say like literally give this game
pros because it was like a horse man
they're going up the hill and the horse
was here we visited State it's
phenomenal definitely games but people
came that crown and it's got all these
why is it if you go and look at these
reviews these ten out of ten no one's
talking about any of the control issues
right and don't talk about our control
issues there's YouTube videos with
hundreds and hundreds of thousand of
views people are having issues with
these controls but we definitely
understand where you come from
Yago and love the poll let's just say
that all right we are gonna get this uh
become place to the last two real quick
we're gonna combine so addict is solve
addict you've got acts old rumors
predictions that kind of thing is soft
I'm assuming you've got one talks on
Black Friday talk so let's combine these
at first you go first yeah I guess the
real quick is that time of year again
Black Friday is upon us and of course
the three major first party
manufacturers are gonna try to find ways
to for you to purchase their system and
their games so from what I've been able
to see me
shout-out to a cheap-ass gamer because
they put out they have a they have a
list and they have a list that they put
out with all the black friday Ad leaks
and then they thankfully put it into a
Google Doc spreadsheet to make it easy
for people to see but I'm gonna be
honest with you guys I think this year
it's a two horse race for like who's
winning Black Friday and I think what's
the competition what welcome to do what
Sony Bing it Sony and I think I think
it's only I think it's Nintendo I
honestly Sony with that $200 doorbuster
spider-man Bunny I don't think that that
is going to be that is gonna go to
everyone now that Xbox offering Xbox
offering $70 off on specific consoles at
hundred dollars off on the X and the S
with with the red that's ending soon
that's ending way before they're
offering the s like 180 something 175
offering the s will I feel like 200 with
a $20 gift card like certain ones like
that target or Kohl's Kohl's you're
getting like a certain amount of
something like that yeah game stops
having some good ones uh and that's just
because they're adding game stuff mm-hmm
right right but it's nothing it's
nothing it's nothing of
manufacturer-specific
right so if we go over to Nintendo
Nintendo has a 300 dollar Mario Kart
bundle which is they had that last year
right that's that is gonna continue to
move um they haven't announced anything
specific for Pokemon and I doubt they
will but you never know come on separate
they know people are going they don't
to tell me you going what they given is
a bundle they taking the three TS and
putting it on top of the switch the
consumer expects you know discounted
products that are like you were two
bundles we don't do this Omo and B money
saying L my craft bundle was what they
give me
yeah Mon crab bundle that's pretty much
it retailer probably do like get an
extra gimme more whatever but this said
any of that stuff
like when you go back to Nintendo they
have all right they have the pre-orders
up for the Pokemon versions apparently
no sort of deal on that no I haven't
talked about it yet then they did the
smart thing of already offering this is
mash bundle for pre-order even though
it's that's a December so you happy
you're able to purchase it on Black
Friday if it's available
oh that's big though that's big that's
huge that's mass console look later yeah
I'm gonna jump in real quick at the end
of the day I don't think none such as
Sony own and me last year we did a big
segment who's gonna win we thought it
was all gonna be Xbox with the X and
switch with the giant and Sony quietly
yeah racked up that Black Friday and
destroyed in the MPD in November I
anything about it this supposedly only
an in-store doorbuster across the board
but for the spider-man bundle what I
mean is the red system no no it's just a
[Applause]
no everybody has it now
I think target yeah everybody I'm
looking at it right now
Best Buy Target Amazon no gamestop yet
Costco Sam's Club Kohl's
I don't think that stops getting it
because they're offering a $50 gift card
with the team so maybe not maybe not
when you name stop despite the [ __ ]
market your ps4 slim I would say you
know still has a chance but not a good
[Music]
and they still have Super Smash Brothers
and their boat wouldn't be sold on Black
Friday nice couldn't really that could
give them to W masters in December
here's the reorder the pre-orders
available to purchase on Black Friday my
issue here is is the market share that
hasn't picked up a switch how many of
them are going to go buy that doesn't
have it now but then of people who are
just waiting for smashed oh yeah REO
between zelda between mario kart but
like there is a lot that the core would
have already picked or not true i think
this is the year where that younger
market really really makes that push for
those switches like I'm telling you
pokemons gonna Pokemon is gonna sell
switches like crazy Pokemon I feel like
Pokemon is solely the reason why
Nintendo projected and then young
Nintendo is well really low-key young
Nintendo they have a kind of stocking
stuffer priced to DS with Mario maker
but like Mario maker are in
built-in by 80 bucks for any what 80 now
it's you to TS is not the one with the
flip is no my son just okay three dears
I'm going to the store what do you think
about like who's coming out when is
Black Friday which it was third place
there's no way it'll be Nintendo this
time hmm oh just cause of like Pokemon
and then getting ready to get smashed
right after yeah yeah I don't know I
think I think like money like revenue
wise I think Nintendo has a good chance
of taking that what I mean like units
sold probably it's probably gonna be but
right now Saab more like right now
they're below their forecast right they
what particular gear Baja and that's not
any two games can do it is behind
remember Nintendo had this oh okay
there's still time that's what I'm
saying like a lot of people are getting
this a lot of these people are thinking
the these forecasts and the stuff like
that those are from analysts right one
of that having Kratos own is for the
fiscal year correct
the annual yeah so you're saying Pokemon
Pokemon and smash you're gonna take care
of that yeah all right Oh attic XO
predictions will be Ganim uh to be
honest with you man like I'm starting to
go into this with like low expectation
so yeah I want to do everything but this
is first off I don't think that I think
this is gonna be slightly better than
Gamescom and like a couple knock is
worse than III like people going in
there with these is like no fable pretty
much they said no faith in it oh you
know I think we might thing going to
game pass or something
like that but I don't think they're
gonna be remaking for a banjo or there's
gonna be sequel announced like this is
inside Xbox like people to remember is
[Laughter]
my do says they might bring back the
cracking back to see if these I can no I
can really see them doing something like
that like this is the new cracking this
crack it has a face and it grabs you
like I can totally see them doing
something like that and to be honest
with you you know if they want to do
some big update and that's part of it
I'm okay with that
I don't really play you okay you okay
with the cracking body I don't care
that's one thing I think we'll see some
games go to game pass I do think that
we're gonna see some Japanese one of
those it's neither
I don't it's neither going to be that
fighting game that's on PlayStation the
Japanese one would say what you told
Molly coos Yakuza
I think the coos are a persona 5 coming
to Xbox one will be like I say for now
but I'm a player right now you know not
persona yeah all right
Twitter gonna be later his persona
jumping man cuz I got some thoughts on
obviously I wish I called bro you know
he he been low-key I was thinking me
hype but giving me hope for crackdown
you know saying like leaks have been
crazy
you know I'm saying and point me wrong
this is the greatest troll ever because
looking at like a game that I was
clowning you know you know Connor with
some hope you know obviously with the 4k
TAC are the saying the cloud destruction
is gonna be in there the four player
co-op people he's saying people are
gonna be really grown away from what
they see and on you know my thing is at
this point just if the game is just
like it's a seven that's exactly stone
the developer for me parsing my wishlist
solid-looking crackdown for show that
you know obsidian would be nice let's do
they give me some ashen no ashen you
haven't heard from it yes I think that's
coming you know what about below the
game past they want you playing a match
let me put the back let me put the
battery with the battery hmm alright the
void has been is there Sony don't do
their Sony a little conference thing
that is they just washed it away they
put it away they they own ad sitting on
a laurels um this new regime and
Microsoft and when I say the new regime
I'm saying Phil right Phil in a squad
because Phil is backed by money now
before it was whole and Phil wallet they
had full wallet inside the Duffy bag he
couldn't get it out so now they release
Phil wallet so while it is working now
right I believe this is gonna be and I
know
Microsoft y'all have heard Phil talking
to me right yeah cuz why Phil is doing
this thing I talk about a boss we do
this thing
um but right now I do hear how the
inside Xbox is crap they know they hear
it they like man how we gonna fix this
Oh dis dis dis EXO has been blowing up
like constantly it's like it's like it's
a trauma yeah
you ready you height and feel it right
you you know why you feel it because I
already know that crackdown is gonna be
a smash success I'm predicting 8.9 a
Metacritic Wow and the reason why the
reason why I'm saying 8.9 and medically
is for the simple fact that
destructibility they would not say that
bro I seen it they would say listen let
me are you going
and I know listen it does have the
energy that it could be different but
with slow-mo I would be money like I'm
not doing it I get caught up in the
hyperbole every inside Xbox and like
chaotic said this is an inside Xbox
regardless store if it's in Mexico City
it is what you call a Major Nelson with
the white gloves the mariachi band they
you know now some good stuff they
announced they bought obsidian if they
show one game from these studios that's
even closer that's what I need
show me do to Nintendo just straight
steal the game plan is show a JPEG of
some to show the JPEG
there you see the reason I don't want to
do that is because the games like
scalebound but at the end of the day
myself able they know fables come back
what if they show scalebound they could
I will retire from YouTube entire take
that back because you got a lot of
people out there that will hound you to
death so I want you to take that back
because your ultimate get back and these
dudes know that they ultimate get back
is to get a game that people thought
they loved and I actually saw I think I
take that back
see I see be money and the chat say he
needs at least two games I think that's
that's unrealistic expectations like
this isn't even III well that's what we
expect to eat three stranded like PP
right to hype I'm not I'm not getting
caught de la perle meta really cautious
about aspect expect nothing so if they
give you something you have you know
what I'm about to start the beginning of
every month
I expect my car to break down the lap oh
it's not what do you what are you hoping
for what you expect I've seen their work
yeah I have and I'm gonna tell you
something I'm gonna tell you something
Nintendo is usually pretty clear about
what they're gonna show you and they let
you know so the weather just watch it or
skip it oh are you 45 minutes of smash
they mean that [ __ ]
they gonna show you smack they go give
you a quiz at the end of all information
[Music]
line when they say they cover in one
game you can't say they lied I mean for
me I'm playing it safe as well I don't
expect super you know amounts of stuff
I'd like to see the Obsidian
announcement and something else that
maybe you weren't expecting some new
titles the game pass what that maybe who
knows actually talked about the elite
controller like the elite controller you
know you know that white color stuff
real quick on the elite controller man I
love that controller but I have to call
them out man like that that those rubber
grips on the side coming off that's not
the move yeah but come on life years
something with the build yeah so that I
mean obviously if the crackdown gameplay
proves that they date the destruction is
in there and it's awesome yeah that
doesn't allow to sort of increase a you
know the the buzz around that game and
the fact that further notice crackdown
can stay in the bushes that's the one
I'm hopeful now to me right now
and I hope they prove me wrong is an
April Fool's joke what they've shown
like the fact that they don't show to e3
the fact that it's they show me from
floor it just get me to me feel like
they knock off a Mexican flag team
controller
I remember this in Mexico but I don't
think they would announce it they're
like obviously you know it could be some
kind of theme yeah when it comes
I don't think they would announce it on
the ether on the inside xbox show but it
could definitely be announced like on
Twitter or something so what do you
think we get any project x cloud news
could be they already talked about it
yeah they could expand and say when the
actual like the beta testing goes out it
might be my beautiful the end of the
year that would be great um that'd be a
nice little touch um and besides that I
think maybe some talk about like the
fourth expansion pass and DLC keep that
game in people's minds
hello man though hello has been mi a ver
nice if that game just dropped and X Oh
fair enough enough Oh real quick just
real quick um biggest thing from a
realistic expectation what do you think
that they would announce the biggest
most highest thing that you think is
possible that you think they might show
some halo footage something no they are
mm so it's not fables or what me
crackdown amazed I thinking I feel what
you go with I've just really go polls
like say ninja theories games gonna give
an ounce okay because the entire
marketing team was just there for some
reason like why would the whole
marketing team be there I don't think
they're in a position to show their game
off unless they're there to show
something off I had heard that they were
already before the the buyout happened
they were already working on the next
thing after him they asked him in that
giant bomb interview uh what what is
[ __ ] there you're working on he's like
oh I can't go into specifics on what
they're working on but I could say
they've been working on it since the
since their lives came dropped since the
last call is that gonna be a mile off
exclusive or is yes something it has to
he saw he said we all sit there be like
yo we understand intended stuff right
well we owe them you know if this is
because he compared it to last
XOS that was his exact analogy
compartment previous EXO's because we
have announced if they go crazy and they
announced a bunch of stuff we don't know
honest guy I'm not there with y'all with
that and it will be ILP 87 and we got yo
the most realistic thing that you think
they would announce most realizing is
probably just some more nonsense coming
at the game by me not once again like I
use game pass religiously I love game
pass I think that's one of the best
things have you sit down my friend
there haven't shown anything I
understand what you're saying they
haven't touted it as that type of show
yeah if I
yeah you the most me personally I think
Phil gonna come out and he gonna do the
swagger jacking again he gonna think oh
he's gonna get out there cuz he knows us
all you ain't in these streets and he's
really like sovereign said DLC talk will
for the armed force of course that's a
given right they're gonna probably give
you a date for the crackdown and I think
that's possible
I'm gonna show you the ninjas theory
game or show you what they're talking
about give it a little blow out on that
so you can have faith in the the studios
that they purchase right then gonna
probably announce two more studios
coming they don't give you a whole bunch
of crack down
so this crackdowns talk could stop and
the hype can build to the game comes out
ashen is probably gonna pop out and drop
out they're gonna probably give you some
below man um honestly I think it'll
probably be like one no IP that we don't
know about other than the game from
Ninja Theory that'll be there I really
think I really think and what I'm saying
it's not like a lot of stuff to be
honest with you
um but
my Peas no think about it
the vegetarians not be there that showed
anything right whatever it is name only
concept maybe whatever he thinks is III
2019 top but it's very small what I'm
saying is very minimum but we have
lowered our expectations to the floor so
bad that even if we say minimal stiff it
sounds like is grandioso it's not this
is very remember when I walk past with
that face listen listen on that next
podcast I'm going to do the same face
tune in without coming with the shades
you get to talk about the cool stuff you
come in with you right let's talk about
the stuff you go where okay let's do
this last question and ask you a
question
obviously he sent out a tweet that kind
of went viral and basically its life to
date sales so that means from when the
PlayStation 4 launch to September 2018
oh yeah let me try to actually do so
basically what's going on here is he has
said you know bait all that he basically
listed what are the games were that you
know all the kind of like the most so
let me get this update so young say let
me know if you have seen it cool cool
so all's presented crow yes so on he's
gotta got that list and what's going on
is life to date so what we see here from
the Playstations launch grand theft auto
number one right on both GTA 5 masculine
is the GTA 5 on both Xbox yeah GTA 5
right so we got a call of duty
all three Call of Duty's you got NBA 2k
battlefield one God of War at number
seven Star Wars Battlefront 2015 call of
duty at nine and in NBA 2k 17 so again
this is from digital full physical
purchase and digital purchase and then
as we see with the Xbox pretty much the
same grand theft
woody the same in battle for big weird
Advent was advanced warfare in number
seven here on xbox and also surprisingly
destiny to write day it's on Xbox list
at number nine all our for non so don't
I want to bring this to the Lords in
reference to exclusives now as you can
see you know on this list you know
especially the police go back to the
by station list you know we're not
seeing the Uncharted we're not seeing
horizon zero dawn so to speak right now
we assume spider-man's gonna get to this
this based on you know next month or
whatever because it's from September but
uh is this an argument against
exclusives and I want to bring that to
the table because we're not seeing the
dominance that uh I was actually
surprised by this list to be honest with
you guys
I thought almost so what do you guys
think about this I think it's a you know
I've always said from day one marketing
do sell your console quicker than
explosives would that is proof of that
you know even remotely some of these you
can you can have an argument against I
mean look at the top three of
PlayStation the world war 2 black ops
like infinite warfare they had the
marketing dose for all of those games
that it should but you know at the end
of that I don't know who gets the 2k
ones um cyber stuff as it but don't they
have a weird thing with it just like a
weird thing with it I would say let me
retract that one say it's exclusively
marketing does but at the end of the day
the games that have that are on that
screen on YouTube the most I generally
sell the best like I don't even think
it's really exclusive there's a reason
god of War's up there and you know if
you look at xbox listen you guys I've is
number 8 which is halo and if you look
at this I'm hate to say it but that
proves that the Xbox I did find it
interesting that destiny 2 was on the
Xbox one list considering that you know
Sony does have the marketing rights
there I was surprised by that I don't
know that means I don't think that means
that destiny to outsold PlayStation I
just think yeah yeah you know the
install base for that install base
destiny to more people of that assault
pick that game up yeah it kind of blows
my mind that GTA
now so everything mmm better every year
but Gea sells more consistently
throughout the years Lord Mayor's let me
get you in man what do you feel about
this do you just dislocate the idea that
exclusive matter I think you know what
man I think this reinforces that fact
here's why talk to me all of those games
that are on both lists
obviously you know that they sold more
on PlayStation why did they sell more on
PlayStation because there's more people
who own PlayStation and why do people
own more Playstations and Xbox is
because they have things there that they
can't get on Xbox mm-hmm or anywhere
else for that matter so yeah I think I
think that's a you just contradicted
your state yeah confused I think that
reinforces and that you went with it the
reason people have a PlayStation is
exclusives exactly it reinforces that
good and that there's three games in the
top you matter the fact that you're
saying that do matter
mm-hmm but yeah because because these
exclusives exist even though they might
not be filling up the top ten of the
most sold games lists the reason why the
systems obviously are what two to one
now because um that very reason because
there's exclusive that goes in line with
mine thinking like I've always said I
think the exclusives serves to create an
identity for that system but they appeal
most to us like the hardcore gamers are
the ones those first 10 million sales on
both consoles that's who the exclusives
appeal to after that it's the casual guy
that wanted a Call of Duty the category
that Call of Duty World War 2 black ops
3 + infinitive warfare is the reason
that
PlayStation is doing so well is because
it's a shows everything every year there
always has a bundle right I really think
that you know Microsoft dropped the ball
when they let when we didn't wait for
that market your theory attic is because
that goes in hain with Sony's aggressive
or getting the licenses
mockingly Oh for these big games that
also really plays a factory where losses
don't help them sell I'm saying that for
every ten consoles sold maybe two or
three or Sofer exclusives okay the rest
was thought because Call of Duty World
War two was on without a commercial and
PlayStation popped up at the end because
I think that's part of it yes but if you
look at the number one game that's a
game that that again comes out once
every eight years we're looking at the
lists are in the right prism um the list
and the question that is posed is not
about sales it's about the actual sales
of the see when you see both lists right
it's not the actual total sales of the
games it's telling you that the
dominance in the top five of each
console has absolutely zero to do with
an exclusive title you would think like
on a Playstation that a god of war will
be number one I'll see uh which we call
it um I think what's the Nathan Drake
uncharted would I'm like number white a
man will be number three oh but what's
not happening in these lists is and it's
being dominated by third-party titles um
and is and the question is posed again
is it are these this exclusive matter to
reach these top top five sold on these
systems played on these systems and it
is showing you that they don't matter at
all because these games they don't it
doesn't matter if these games are
released or not the questions we impose
they're still not dominating top five
and either console because I'm gonna
have a question but what about to solve
point what she said okay here's what
you're saying but the exclusives create
the identity you know and people take
that consideration but I think
if this does not I feel like exclusives
meant the way that people you know claim
they do people go on these giant rats on
Twitter they'd at least be three
exclusives on that list come from
hardcore gamerz sovereign is saying
sovereign is completely right in
exclusives build the identity of the
system that builds the cult following
right
we are regardless of what if you don't
believe that you're in a cult you crazy
the reason why Nintendo's list isn't up
here is one they don't have those
third-party games actually if you look
at their themselves I bet you nintendo
would have outsold some of these with
their exclusives in itself we're talking
about the rankings in these games for
these tight for these systems and what
we're missing here is just take the top
five right top five in both categories
in both in both systems no not one of
them have an exclusive game so
exclusives don't matter when it comes to
reaching the top five and most games
sold per system now in making us
identity
yes sovereign is completely right in
that identity fact that people gravitate
to where they play it right yet first
yes one more question okay what about
two addicts point with as far as marking
this like because with the third poll I
think that works I think that works in
selling systems right now this that's
some totally different from what is
posed here right correct correct
all right now an overall sales base of
systems like sovereign said when you see
a commercial Call of Duty and at the end
play on PlayStation boom nothing yeah
you really for the casual person thinks
oh I only buy that they're you know he's
not considering the fact that he can buy
some place else hell no it said
PlayStation that's where he's gonna go
purchase so it doesn't matter we
and I'm gonna keep saying we because
that's what my blood is that mom we lost
the battle when we won had misdirection
in the beginning - lost all those
exclusive deals that we had when that
happened slowly took over and he swooped
in and they got all of these things
locked down it's funny to see destiny on
Xbox Live yeah but that was interested
mm-hmm remember this is isolated list on
game said I'm disappointed to see
fallout 4 and Xbox so many losers
at the end of the day you know I'm not
saying exclusive I think where your
friends play play more of a matter than
we're exclusive yeah because people will
go people will buy another constant play
exclusives but don't play where their
friends are I think marketing does have
way because we're talking about when it
comes to the hard cold we're a small
percentage of the actual game gaming
community I do think hardcore gamers
have a huge curve on where the console
sales end up more hardcore gamers with
the B s4 at the B end of generation so
the domino effect their friends about
the ps4 their friends bought the ps4 and
their family bought the ps4 because the
biggest bokor than what's a PlayStation
at the beginning of the generation so it
was a domino effect from what from their
circle because one person adds up to two
two titles before it adds up quick
that's why they say whoever gets to the
first ten million generally wins the
whole console or entire console
generation it just goes where your
friends that's the biggest incentive to
where you're going to play is where your
friends are doesn't know why because Joe
walking billboard yeah you're walking
billboard for your system Lord kognito
and I'm gonna give you a very small fan
since I know we got to get out of here
Lord Cognito swings that switch stick
crazy hard alright let me tell you he's
out here and everybody talks to octave
as a developer or whatever he plants his
teeth in
head for the switch stuff alright I
don't care who it is he will - he could
be standing in line and a restaurant and
get a game of talker pop up but that's
twitch though and when you turn into
that fan and you enter that cult of that
whatever group you're in you spit out
and regurgitate stuff to resonate with
that person to convert him to your team
PlayStation has done a wonderful job
this time
right there's a lot of that stuff on one
and I see how rabid it is and disgusting
it is in certain spots on Twitter
they're very bad with it they come at
you very hard pause but you have to
understand that the reason why that 10
million means so much is because you
have 10 million little heads running
around telling people where a game and a
lot of times they're in game stops and
when you come in to buy a xbox you might
walk out with a Playstation if you got
the right guy in front mmm listen I mean
doppel given I've heard you use gonna
say something no I mean it all it all
coming in to tell a very very
interesting stories and that like a king
with saving saying the top 5 or all of
the not exclusives what they they are
all multiplayer games and like addict
was pointing out it for me and we I know
I know a lot of people and for me in my
workspace and where I exist
they all went with Playstation because
that's what the majority of people we
knew had and you want to play with your
people and that just makes I mean that
makes sense why would you want to play
multiple your games you know where there
are like your friends don't exist inter
that's why I wish I would have known
about Xbox Xbox controller before Call
of Duty and things like that but I mean
that's just the story it is and that's
the story you you have to tell when you
go out you tell your friends about
consoles you know I got this because
come play with come play with us well so
let's be clear like GTA 5 to the labels
point GTA 5 is up there because of GTA
online and now because a five brother
like GTA 5 would have
would have slowed down in terms of sales
if it was still just a single-player
experience so much of what that game is
now is GTA online that's where that that
that's where those purchases are coming
from and then we gotta think about this
logistics like these are these
third-party games that aren't out on
both consoles they're gonna sell more
than the and then exclusive the
exclusive has to be super gangbusters
right you compete with more games the
point
so yeah before we get out here I was
interested that is interesting numbers
like this it kind of blew my mind the
halo was out so destiny on console on
and follow yeah I like this so when do
our people win a game of the generation
or critically acclaimed title the red
dad gotta watch spider-man
scores a perfect ten by media outlets
does your view change if minor flaws are
found during the gameplay experience
the choices are egg no mine and ethnics
cannot effect a masterpiece yes any
floors found automatically disqualify
attend sea only if the floor disruptor
affects the main gameplay experience or
be I don't care unless it's quick HDR
small puddles or the word boy is where
it goes Lord Aleppo a Lord absolute
pulling double duty for the realm Lord
Aleppo where can I find people find you
and what do you have going along sir
well you can find us on YouTube doing
what we always do providing you great
information and education with a touch
of humor and on Twitter
as a perp of poper us we post our our
updates on what's going on on our
channel but we all also have individual
Twitter's in which we talk and you know
make fun of games and stuff like that on
there too so you can find us there as
well
nice I think some more hero unlock man I
like that series really good series with
protagonists love are you gonna be doing
villains too we will be doing villains
we will be doing villains we just
haven't figured out who it is that we
want to start with because we want to be
perfect
guys very unique great humor
high-quality video editing and like I
said great unique things doing stuff
different than a lot of young man please
subscribe to channel great guy friend to
the realm always a pleasure to have that
balance Nintendo switch talk up in the
round build it - he was holding it down
coming in last minute damn we can find
people find thank you so much brother
for coming in to do remember the lords
thanks everybody uh I can find me on
Twitter at real medications we talked
about pretty much talked about MMA in
gaming let's talk about it I haven't
been playing no games leave they haven't
been up to nothing because I've been
training my tail off as of late thanks
for having me I appreciate you bro like
I said we definitely talk at combat talk
that was refreshing someone that speaks
our language really good good to see you
I had please follow medication she's a
good follow on Twitter y'all Lord addict
in his debut out the back door sliding
glad to have you tell anybody how you
you have to come here next week because
everybody was a filament salute for
coming wrong know what solve what is
going on in I'm not doing anything to
playing reg know my mom is Capades like
III probably twitch of you playing I
mean I don't care if you don't say
anything I think you should just do it
because doing story stuff like we can
call it the wonderful world of sob so
that's what I'm gonna be doing shout out
to med to shout out to dalabo for coming
through and you can find me on Twitter
Lord saw my LP and vxr8 on Xbox Live and
PSN Lord came bringing the floor alright
first I want to uh
shout out I were to guess and I'm start
with Mitch first um thank you for
showing up it was a surprise I didn't
know that she was coming through and I
swear to god I think I know you but the
fact that you said you like to fight a
lot I don't think we're gonna hang out
because yeah I don't want to constantly
made you back-to-back oh thank you for
showing up and it was love the
positivity I'm gonna you know add you on
Twitter and see what mortis or combat
stuff is because I need more background
in combat so yeah let's get let's talk
on that I'm doing that a lot of you guys
don't know when I was in pinch I ran
straight
to him because I watch his uh just shows
his I don't want to call on podcast
because his shows encapsulated and nice
episodes it put together with such an
edit in such an i man and such humor
that you would be doing yourself a
disservice by not checking it out he
right or so I went to him and I told him
um yo need help because we're doing
we're going to LA and I need the swag
and tag and I need the t-shirts he's
like I got you
without without anything I got you we
did a session who did one take and no he
was just like you know cuz he he under
he is how I get into character behind
closed doors we are we have a good
rapport we talked on some other merch
stuff them the man's mind is in a mind
frame of greatness and we we like to
keep greatness close so he's always know
greatness he's on a precipice of exactly
where he wants to be and I and I see
that in you sir hopefully also we can
get those Lost Tapes
of actually recorded properly but I'm
always there for this brother because he
was there for me when my back was
against the wall and he produced quality
because if you listen to those swagger
tags and you listen to the t-shirts he
did the work and he put it out and the
brother helped us when we needed it most
and I do appreciate it and I love saying
you you know doing anything positive man
I love the fact that you came back to
the room I know I went on a little bit
long but this guy can't get enough
adulation and and and thanks from me
what he did for us
facts and and if we are wondering when
we do our prediction series every III
nor do I pose that may last one of them
takes them the verbal takes the way
edited up that's how I got man so much
appreciate Lord Allah PO coming through
for that yeah man same thing like I said
obviously you know what it is you know
make sure you hit that like and
subscribe we know that smash giveaway is
out there please all the links in the
description is reference to that and
then also I want to shout out the stream
team and we got some good reviews up
lost Naldo he's got Cola Cthulhu review
up on our podcast YouTube channel check
it out if you're interested
lady l-boogie she has the NBA 2k
playgrounds - that's up there check that
out on car Bowser's gonna have all you
up in the link in the description as you
already know Lords we are now on Spotify
as well get out
no more announcements to come but we
will reserve it to the smash giveaway
that's in description
obviously the royalty rolls back swag
with the the latest flavors to let us
lay this color waves searched each side
I'm saying when to comment please
support us with and obviously the patron
because again we saw is doing these
patrons you see anything people willing
so you will have a chance to
so like I said validate what it was it
was the one with the commercial with
[Laughter]
obviously combat talk with the King
that's coming right all 39 will my man
Lord Eve artist that's up just like for
solo was talking at destiny talks you
already know what it is if anybody has
anything else crazy oh yeah that's my do
everybody enjoy your Sunday peace